cyber security is one of the most in
demand and fast growing fields in the
world today as more and more aspects of
Our Lives depend on digital Technologies
the need to protect them from malicious
attacks also increases but how do you
become a cyber security professional do
you need a degree in cyber security to
enter this field and is it worth the
time money and effort to pursue one the
answer to these questions is not
straightforward as there are many
factors to consider when deciding
whether a cyber security degree is right
for you in this video we will explore
some of the pros and cons of getting a
cyber security degree as well as some
alternative paths to consider but before
we begin with this video make sure to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
press the Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn so let's
understand the growing importance of
cyber
security cyber security is no longer
afterthought for businesses and
organization it's a core component of
their strategies as technology continues
to advance so do the tactics of cyber
criminals from data breaches to
ransomware attacks and identity theft
the consequence of cyber security
threats can be devastating the impact of
these cyber dangers can be very harmful
to prevent these threats companies and
groups must take cyber security
seriously they need to put safeguards in
place to protect their system data and
customers it's not something that can be
overlooked in fact it should be a top
priority a breach in security can lead
to financial losses and damage to a
company's reputation as technology keeps
advancing it's crucial for businesses to
keep up with the latest cyber security
practices to stay safe they must be
vigilant and prepared to defend against
cyber threats cyber security is no
longer just a choice it's a necessity
all right so this was about the growing
importance of cyber security in today's
world now let's have a look at some pros
of a cyber security degree the
increasing Reliance on technology the
internet and Cloud Services means that
more sensitive data is at risk this is
where cyber Security Professionals comes
into play they are responsible for
safeguarding digital assets protecting
privacy and preventing potential
catastrophes the significance of their
role in today's society cannot be
overstated a cyber security degree can
provide you with many benefits such as a
solid foundation of Technical and
theoretical knowledge a cyber security
degree can teach you the fundamental
concepts principles and techniques of
cyber security such as cryptography
network security malware analysis
digital forensics ethical hacking and
more you can also learn about the legal
ethical and social aspects of cyber
security such as data privacy compliance
and governance next is a Competitive
Edge in the job market yes it provides
you a Competitive Edge in the job market
a cyber security degree can demonstrate
your commitment credibility and
competance to potential employees
according to 2009 19 report by burning
glass Technologies 88% of cyber security
job up postings requires at least a
bachelor's degree and a cyber security
degree can also help you meet the
eligibility criteria for certain
certifications such as cissp or cism
which can boost your career prospects
and salary potentials all right so the
third one is a wide range of career
options so a degree in cyber security
provides you a wide range of career
options and opportunities
a cyber security degree can open the
door to various roles and sectors in the
cyber security field such as information
security penetration tester security
engineer security consultant cyber
threat intelligent analyst and more you
can also work in different industries
that need cyber Security Professionals
such as Finance Healthcare government
education retail and more next one is
cons of a cyber security degree so let's
have a look at this so so a cyber
security degree also has some drawbacks
such as first is a high cost and time
commitment a cyber security degree can
be expensive and timec consuming to
complete so depending on the level of
type of degrees you choose associate
Bachelor Masters you may need to spend 2
to six years of a full-time study and
pay tens of thousands of dollars in the
tution fees you may also need to take
out like student loans or work part-time
to finance your education next one is a
fast changing and dynamic field a cyber
security degree can provide you with the
strong Foundation of Knowledge and
Skills but it may not be enough to keep
up with the ever evolving nature of
cyber security cyber threats are
constantly changing and becoming more
sophisticated while new technologies and
tools are emerging and disrupting the
field you may need to update your skills
and knowledge regularly through
self-learning online courses
certification or continuing education
programs so now the third one which is a
challenging and stressful work
environment so a cyber security degree
can prepare you for a challenging and
rewarding career but it can also expose
you to a high pressure and demanding
work environment you may need to deal
with tight deadlines heavy workloads
complex systems unpredictable situations
and constant threats you may also face
ethical dilemas legal issues or
emotional stress from dealing with
sensitive data or
incidents so this was about the cons of
a cyber security degree so we have
covered pros and cons of a cyber
security degree now next we will move on
to the next topic which is alternatives
to a cyber security
degree so a cyber security degree is not
only a way to enter or advance in cyber
security field there are some
alternative paths that you can consider
such as boot camps boot camps are
intensive training programs that teach
teach you the practical skills and tools
needed for a specific role or domain in
cyber security they usually last from
weeks to a few months and are delivered
online or in person by experts or
instructors they can help you gain
hands-on experience through projects or
simulations and prepare you for the
certifications or job interviews one of
the example is Caltech cyber security
boot camp by simply learn through this
boot camp you will gain all the relevant
skills and a celtech CME boot camp
certificate so a boot camp basically is
a good alternative to a cyber security
degree for various reasons now coming to
the another alternative of a cyber
security degree that is
certifications so certifications are the
credentials that validate your Knowledge
and Skills in a specific area of topic
of cyber security so they are usually
offered by professional organizations or
vendors and require you to pass an exam
or complete a project
they can help you demonstrate your
competance and credibility to employers
or clients and enhance your career
opportunities or salary potential some
examples of this kind of certifications
are the cyber security Masters program
professional certificate program in
cyber security Advanced executive
program in cyber security
Etc so if you are looking to become a
cyber security expert and gain handsome
salary packages then have a look at a
wide range of cyber security courses by
simply learning in collaboration with
top universities across the globe by
enrolling in any of these certification
programs you will gain expertise in
skills ethical hacking penetration
testing defensive cyber security
cryptography ransomware analysis malware
analysis firewalls network security
vulnerability assessment and much more
so what are you waiting for just hurry
up and enroll Now find the course Link
in the description box so now coming to
the next next alternative that is
self-learning yes self-learning is a
process of acquiring new skills and
knowledge on your own using various
resources and methods you can use books
blogs podcast videos online courses or
other materials to learn about cyber
security and the topics related to cyber
security that interest you or are
relevant to your goals you can also use
online platforms tools or labs to
practice your skills and test your
knowledge some example of self-learning
resources are cybery hack the box or try
hacking so this was about the
alternatives to a cyber security degree
so whether a cyber security degree is
worth it or not depends on your goals a
degree can help you get certain jobs but
there are other ways to succeed like
getting certifications or learning on
your own think about what you want to do
how much money you have and what you
want to learn it's important to keep
learning learning about cyber security
because it's always changing the value
of degree is about how well it helps you
to reach your goals in the cyber
security world so choose what's best for
you based on what you want to achieve
all right guys with that we have come to
the end of this video If you like this
video please give it a thumbs up I hope
it really help you all thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upscaling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here